I'm live first YouTube mobile livestream
since YouTube enabled live-streaming
for all channels with 10,000 or more
subscribers let's see if I can get my
camera a little bit better aligned here
I have no idea what to expect as far as
this goes I just have no clue how this
even works or anything and I'm not even
seeing I'm not even seeing the
livestream on our channel I'm looking
for it right now people are talking to
me though so it must be how did you
people find this my channel says that
there's no my channel says there's no
livestream but people are already
calling me a [ __ ] so it must it must be
working hey question is this is this on
the David Pakman show channel or is this
on the David Pakman Channel like is this
my personal channel or is this the show
channel see if somebody says yes someone
said show channel ok Wow
well I wish I could watch my own live
stream I seem unable to do so right now
live streaming let's see I'm gonna get
to some material in a second but I'm
just not seeing
oh it's streaming now ok yeah so I'm
live right now cool well anyway so I
don't know exactly
I've been doing some of these on
Facebook before and people seem to have
a lot of political questions etc etc so
I'm glad to answer questions I have to
admit that the comments are happening
much faster than I'm able to even keep
up with them um let's see here let's see
what we've got
I'm trying to monitor my own stream I'm
told the stream is good alright
well let's just take some questions I
don't know how did Trump become
president I think we've dealt with that
one before
I think that wait a second am i having
like the selfie camera issue is this
showing up correctly like can you read
this looks backwards to me I don't know
if I'm having the selfie problem it's
not reverse okay
good all right let's see if I can
actually get this working so I can
actually see what people are saying I
mean this is this is just insane okay
slow down live chat that's that's
something you can do not not seeing how
to do that man
this is just this is not like the old
days of live-streaming that I can tell
you for sure I wish I could even keep up
with the comments so can somebody tell
me how to slow down in the comments
because I'm barely even evil able to
keep up with them that I can't even read
all the anti-semitic comments because
they're coming in so quickly scroll up
and slow down slowly hey here's a
serious question about the comments I've
been told that there's this new feature
on YouTube live events where people can
basically pay to put their comment at
the top of the comment list for a
certain amount of time it's called like
smart chat or something like that is
that on right now does anybody know if
that's on right now I'm curious about
how that works I don't know no it's not
on you now I know that it's on this
someone saying that that's on you now
I've heard of you now let's see if I go
to the watch page let's see here yeah I
don't know I don't know how that works
but that would be something something to
look at okay I'm now properly set up to
actually deal with this and there's
there's 500 people watching which is
great okay let's
actually try to address some of the
questions that are going on here
how is impeaching Trump going I'd say
it's going what moderately well I mean
certainly he's he's doing enough to get
himself impeached it's just a question
of is anybody going to actually try to
do something about it what other
questions do we have here
impeachment projections I would say
tomorrow do I have pets I don't have
pets what's my opinion of the dollar
value falling for other countries to buy
more American goods I'm not exactly sure
if that's that's worded in the easiest
way to figure out what that's about I
don't know if anybody saw today's show a
lot of people finding this very very
funny already
okay maybe I'll say like I will take I
have to admit this this is going much
better than I imagined and in the sense
of the number of people that are
actually watching right now
what about questions related to should I
restrict questions to like a certain
subject I don't even really know how to
manage this entire thing what is my
opinion on the organization if not now
see now that's a nice and tidy specific
question I've not heard of the
organization and I couldn't possibly
comment about it let's see what other
questions pop up here that I can
actually address specifically Kellyanne
conned me yeah I don't know if you
already listened to today's show I've
sort of started referring to Kellyanne
Conway as Kellyanne conned me
and people seem to be reacting
positively to it I don't know if that's
I don't know maybe maybe that's the new
thing Kellyanne conned me because it's
one con after another
have I seen america-first videos from
other country no I have not
how old am i I look seventeen now that's
a comment that I like I just turned 33
so if people think I'm 17 that's I must
be doing something right I don't know
what it would it would be thoughts on
kevin O'Leary running from Prime
Minister of Canada did that is is that
happening I've not heard that that's
happening if he did I wouldn't vote for
him if I were Canadian what do I think
of marine lepen in France I'm against
how should foreign leaders interact with
Trump ah this is good
I don't think foreign leaders should
interact with Trump as if he's a serious
person I think that they should interact
with him as if something has gone very
wrong and a small handed orange kid is
somehow running the country and I think
that that's the way they should interact
with him I don't think that I mean
really are they going to be able to
pretend like he's a normal elected
official when they're in a room with him
it's hard to imagine raucous Stilson
rocky Stillson wants to know where I
went to school I went to the University
of Massachusetts Amherst and I'm
actually drinking coffee currently out
of my UMass mug for undergraduate and
then I went to graduate school at
Bentley University here in the Boston
area am i wearing girls underwear again
today nope not today
do I think suicide is better than
political action no I don't see if I can
move my camera a little bit here there
we go all right I guess that's is that
is that better I don't even know I don't
know what what it's even considered good
on this thing let's see if I can tighten
it up man this is I need better planning
for this the cameras just moving on its
own slowly this way I guess I have to
move with it in order to stay in the
frame this seems crazy do all Americans
believe Germans are all Nazis no
definitely not
what's my view on tax resistance says
anonymous squad caste that's a good
question I plan to do a segment on tax
resistance next week I've been getting a
bunch of emails from people saying David
you should really address this man that
this thing
we'll just not stay up let's see if I
really need to tighten it so that we
don't have I can't be moving constantly
on the camera it's still moving I think
I've developed a perpetual motion device
because no matter how much I turn my
tripod it then just keeps moving and
moving I I believe I feel like I've made
a scientific discovery of sorts here I'm
gonna be talking about tax resistance
soon but I think that there's definitely
something interesting there Frieda says
ask ask this list what stories we would
like you to pursue
I'm always half half or more of the show
is stories that people in the audience
have come up with so by all means feel
free to suggest stories although the
comments are happening so quickly they
may get last year just use the contact
form at david pakman.com ok do I know
anyone who was involved with the
Protection activity at the Dakota access
pipeline I know a bunch of journalists
who went up there but I don't know any
sort of like random people I guess that
were involved in in what was going up
got going on at the Dakota access
pipeline I'm still just genuinely
curious what is going on with with my
tripod here I think I've now tightened
it up in a way where it won't move
anymore there we go I think we've done
it ok let's see what stories I'm
thinking about for the Monday Friday and
Monday show already let me pull those up
and see what people think about those
because production starts very very
early we we go into the production phase
of shows well in advance of when the
shows actually happen so I'm looking
that there's been another Russian
journalist who has been diagnosed with
severe point that the camera just will
not stay up I I don't know what to do
here I've sort of done everything I can
think of to keep it to keep it stable
and it's sort of going from bad to worse
let's see
is this working I don't know is someone
criticizing the color of the blinds that
they're cream-colored is that or is that
not allowed now I mean I can't I can't
believe that that that is a serious
issue at this point in America a bunch
of people have pointed me to an article
in The Guardian called misinformation
starts to lean left under Trump and of
course the right wing trolls have said
Oh David you're never going to cover
that story because it's a story that
makes progressives look bad
no I plan to cover the story I haven't
looked at the data yet but The Guardian
is saying that under Trump
misinformation is starting to lean left
what is the mission what is defined as
misinformation what what does it mean
that it's leaning left what entities are
being included in that so I'm going to
be looking at that story maybe for
tomorrow's show maybe for next week the
other thing I don't know if people are
aware of this and I I don't know if I'll
get to this on tomorrow's show but
hopefully on Monday debbie Wasserman
Schultz you would think that she's sort
of receding into the the dark abyss of
politics and is not going to be heard
from again but she's actually been
climbing in terms of her position in
Congress and it's stunning to me that
anybody would be saying Oh
after what happened let's give debbie
Wasserman Schultz more power I mean it
just makes absolutely no sense to me
and then also you've if you've probably
seen those Comcast commercials where
they say oh we have the fastest internet
or whatever and obviously I immediately
don't believe almost anything that I see
in ads from Internet service providers
an advertising board has now said you
know you can't really say that Comcast
you don't really have the fastest
internet so you're not actually allowed
to say it and I plan to cover that on
probably on Monday not exactly an urgent
story I would say okay let's see what
other questions we have here Jay Ann
wants to know how do I deal with my
Asian
family members supporting Trump when
they deny Trump is actually racist
against them well you know if you can't
actually point to how Trump is racist
against your Asian family members you
may want to make a different argument
maybe an argument among I don't know
economic lines or maybe make an argument
among a some other path I mean it's hard
to convince someone that Trump is racist
against them if they don't feel that I
don't know that it's going to be too
easy to to demonstrate that a lot of
anti-semitic comments happening I feel
like there's this thing going on where
when we upload a video that's clearly
not live there's always anti-semitic
comments but there's something about
because this is live people seem to be
extra interested in making anti-semitic
comments about me I I don't know why I
guess it may be maybe the anti-semites
get off on the idea that I might see
their their anti-semitic comment live or
something like that but yes the
anti-semites very much emboldened here
in the comments section Jonathan Gomes
is asking whether I think CNN is doing a
better job of reporting as a result of
Trump becoming president I don't know
about that I mean I think CNN is not
doing anything drastically different
under Trump but I think there's more
attention being paid to them because
they were called out as hey can you
called out his fake news by Donald Trump
where now they're more attention is
being paid to them and I think
progressive news sites are definitely
more proactively sort of praising CNN
when they just kind of like tell the
truth about what what's going on
undeniable fact and so I think the
perception of CNN mate maybe has changed
but I don't know that CNN is really
doing anything differently Ian wants to
know whether I'm taking questions from
the live chat Ian's by telling you that
yes I am I am confirming that I am
taking questions in the live chat some
people want me to talk about pizza gate
yeah I mean I've talked about pizza gate
before I if you're hoping for some kind
of big
alysus of the the minutiae of pizza gate
from me I'm not exactly prepared to do
that today and again the reason I
haven't done it on the show is when I
said should I cover pizza gate in the
way where I would actually you know go
through piece by piece what the
allegations are and analyze emails and
Instagram pictures and whatever by and
large people said no it's not worth
doing that so I didn't do it okay
question two people in the who are
watching live should should I ban or
block the people who are just trolling
like posting [ __ ] and jus and stuff like
that or should I just ignore them I
don't know if they would be more aroused
by me confirming I'm aware of them by
immediately blocking them or whether
instead I should just ignore them
totally because they want attention Wow
a lot of people saying ban them honestly
there's just too many of them to ban I
think I would need help I'd need to make
someone a moderator imagine that and
have them them deal with it because it's
it's getting pretty hectic someone's
suggesting that I'm dating a transgender
person some of the speculation is I'm
dating a transgender woman others saying
I'm dating a transgender man yeah
neither neither of those is true I don't
know that there'd be anything to
criticize if I was dating a transgender
person okay do I believe Trump is
mentally ill I don't know about that I
think it's hard to say you know I
interviewed a guy a few weeks ago who
said Trump has a sort of clinical
narcissism problem and it was
interesting to hear the the perspective
mental illness I guess it depends on
what you mean mental illness I do think
and if I'm doing a bunch of interviews I
actually let's see I have the list here
tomorrow morning at 8:05 I'm going to be
on the Backson O'Brien show which is
from where the David Pakman show started
in western Massachusetts it's a morning
show there they want to talk to me about
my coverage of whether Donald Trump can
read I'm also going to be doing Irish
radio about what
Donald Trump can read etc I don't
literally believe that Donald Trump
can't read but I think it's increasingly
clear that he has sort of limited
literacy and is not reading at at what
we would consider an adult level and
that that's not mental illness but it
certainly could be a learning disability
of sorts let's see what else do we have
here people saying they really like
Trump will I do another interview with
Aubrey de Grey
I would love to we've done I think at
this point five interviews with Aubrey
de Grey who works on curing aging which
he sees as a condition to be cured I
would be super interested in having him
back on I don't want to have him on too
often but I would be interested in
having him back on do I believe
pornography is a public health crisis no
I think that there is an elected
official in Utah who believes that it is
a public health problem but I don't
believe that it is a public health
problem
Mangala Kanaga rajah saying that islam
is anti-semitic there was no doubt that
extremist Islam is anti-semitic do i
watch the reuben report i watch some of
Dave's comments for sure his direct
messages I guess they're called I
honestly i text with dave rubin more
than i watch his show and you know he's
in the middle of i don't know he's
taking heat from everybody lately and i
know that there's a bunch of discussions
on our reddit discussion forum about
that by the way you should participate
on reddit we now have with the latest
count i think roughly 2500 yeah just
under twenty five hundred of our viewers
are on our reddit david pakman.com slash
read it we get a ton of stories from
there so i encourage you to check that
out what do I think of Keith Olbermann
you know I've not seen I I think I've
seen about a minute of Keith Olbermann's
new thing that I think he's doing for GQ
I believe it is and I like it I like it
but I just have
such limited time to watch other stuff
you know so yeah I have not I have not
seen that much of it somebody asking
what the point of this livestream is I
have no idea I mean I basically got a
message a couple days ago saying hey
anybody with 10,000 subscribers on
YouTube can now livestream from their
mobile phones and I thought hey we've
got more than 10,000 subscribers I
should try that and I guess I mean
there's nearly a thousand I just
connected on a whim as I'm drinking my
my david pakman show coffee now
available on our website now and we have
nearly a thousand people watching live
just on a whim so I think that that's
good I think that that is uh that is
something that is really really good
although I'm not exactly sure what the
direction of this entire thing is okay
people wanting me to send messages to
dave rubin that he murdered reason that
dave rubin is the [ __ ] of my low you na
police etc etc suggestions that I
interview Sam Harris I am I'll be
completely upfront I've tried to get Sam
Harris on the show before he has never
responded I got a retweet from Sam on
Twitter when we did the sort of analysis
or criticism of reza aslan back in
january of 2016 the first piece that
former intern and current segment
producer noah ferguson of the david
pakman show researched and he retweeted
that after dave rubin tweeted it and
then we've never heard back from sam
harris i would love to have him on i
think there would be a lot to talk about
we could address a lot of different
things I don't think I have to tell most
of the people watching here why that
would be an interesting interview okay
am i against social justice warriors I
did a video about this I already did a
video about this let me see if I can
find it on our YouTube channel sjw let's
see well David I think it's called will
disavow social justice warriors or
something like that it was a live caller
from a few weeks ago I think it's too
simplistic to say oh yeah because it's
called
should the left denounced social justice
warriors and identity politics I
addressed that in pretty significant
detail there so I don't think we
necessarily have to do that again okay
we'll Trump last four years great
question great question I don't know the
answer I initially thought that Donald
Trump was absolutely going to last for
years lately I'm less sure and then of
course some people think of course he's
gonna last for years he's gonna last
eight years and it's gonna be big ly
good and America is gonna be great and
all that stuff okay I saw a question
just scroll by about the Ninth Circuit
decision on the immigration ban there's
not been a decision yet right I think
I'm looking here yeah I'm not seeing
that maybe the question was what do I
think the decision will be listen I
don't think that there is going to be I
believe the Ninth Circuit will agree
that the ban is off and that it has to
stay off the Ninth Circuit is generally
known to be relatively liberal and I
think even without a liberal
interpretation this is a band that makes
absolutely no sense and I just don't see
I don't I don't see them putting turning
the band back on so to speak for lack of
a better term okay would I interview
David Fromm yes I would
am i a Democrat or a Republican I've
been I've always been a Massachusetts
voter and I've never been registered to
either party am I satisfied that Donald
Trump can read I am absolutely satisfied
that Donald Trump can read at a sort of
basic level but I don't think that
Donald Trump is reading as an adult
level would I interview reycarts while
we've tried to interview him he is not
written back I would I would absolutely
love to have him on
okay some questions I'm getting about
what's going on in the chat is something
wrong with the chat I'm not aware of
anything that's wrong with the chat I
[Music]
the the chat seems to be working fine if
something please tell me if something's
not working in the chat exactly what is
it that's that's not working in the chat
yeah
will I go on that Christensen's show
I've never heard of that
Jason Unruh interview
I'm not offhand familiar with who that
is sounds vaguely familiar do I hate
Islam no I don't hate Islam any more
than I hate any particular religion
would I do a roundtable with Kyle
kolinsky I presume and Genki ogor sure
about what I don't know but I would do a
roundtable people asking me to comment
about mark dice I've seen one of Mark
dices video and one of his videos and
don't really know much about him so I
can't say too much about that how does
America prepare for the 2020 election
you don't wait till 2020 I mean that
that's really how you prepare you've got
to start now there's 2017 gubernatorial
elections the midterms in 2018 issues
related to redistricting issues related
to state senators and state
representative I mean there's just so
much you prepare for 2020 by doing a ton
to try to get our elected officials in
total to be more progressive before we
get to 2020 interview George Noory
that's an interesting idea what's my
opinion on steven crowder I've seen a
couple of his videos I saw a video of
him going to again my alma mater the
University of Massachusetts at Amherst
and he was with Milo in a palace and the
the so-called fact she called herself a
you know that woman the Cristina woman
the gamergate lady and steven crowder
was basically like berating the audience
I said that's that's one of the few
things
of Steven Crowder's that I've ever seen
yeah Christina Hoff Sommers as super
free education said there that so that
I'm not hugely hugely familiar with him
what's my opinion on the Kellyanne
Conway or Kellyanne conned me as I like
to call her promoting Ivanka's clothing
line my opinion is that there are legal
experts who think that she may have
broken ethics laws by doing it and when
you hear someone in the Trump
administration broke ethics laws you
respond by saying who cares because
nobody is going to hold them accountable
let's see a bunch of people asking my
opinion about Justice Democrats I'll be
honest I don't know much about it I know
that Kyle kolinsky and Genki ogor are
involved in it and I was chatting with
Kyle the other day and we were thinking
about doing an interview about it I
don't know that much about it I know
that they have the Justice Democrats
wiki says that they have a hundred and
ten thousand members I don't even know
enough to know what it means to be a
member like is that have members given
money does anybody know maybe you put in
your email address on the Justice
Democrats website okay I don't know but
I hope that I get a chance to interview
Kyle about it that would be good
George says f you David these are [ __ ]
questions well I'm not the one asking
the question so I don't know what to
tell you
why are your mods on Reddit not American
I honestly have no idea whether the
moderators on our reddit discussion
forum are American or not unlike being
President of the United States you don't
have to be American to moderate the
David Pakman show
reddit discussion forum after all
someone's saying I don't know world war
two truth and facts sound like a
Holocaust denier right if you go to a
dinner party and you start accusing
someone of not knowing the real facts
about World War two if you have to bet
that person is to some degree a
Holocaust denier yeah oh I see GT is a
definitely a Holocaust denier I think
we're gonna ban that person because
they're really really annoying and
actually you know what I'm gonna take
this opportunity to ban a few people
that are monopolizing the chat here yeah
what's the point of that I just don't do
you gonna achieve by going on a live
YouTube stream and just putting stuff
that makes no sense
Katie cool wants to know if I'll do more
interviews like the one we did with
Richard Stallman yeah that interview
shockingly I had no idea what to expect
our producer Rachel know knew Richard
Stallman and said you've got to look
this guy up and we should interview him
and because he refuses to use Skype we
actually brought him into the studio and
we have an interview up on YouTube
called the Richard Stallman explains
everything or something like that and
it's endlessly fascinating I mean he's a
very quirky guy to say the least and
after this is a story I will tell at
some point after the interview Richard
Stallman asked me to give him a ride I
think he wanted a ride all the way back
to MIT but I offered to give him a ride
back to the subway and it was about a
seven or eight minute ride and it was
absolutely titillating and fast lated
fascinating and I'll maybe get into that
a little more I want to talk to Rachel
about what would be okay to say before I
just tell the entire story but for
people who don't know Richard Stallman
is a tech guy who created something
called canoe which is the free software
on which Linux is based and this is like
a really specific thing that Linux is
not new Linux is based on canoe or
something like that so anyway check that
interview out it's pretty interesting
okay I don't know what else did really
do in this live stream I mean I'm sort
of answering questions it's just really
a test and
people are watching live right now and
and you know I mean I guess I may be
doing this on some kind of schedule
would be interesting or may be wrapping
up our production day with a live stream
and then based on what people suggest
for the next day's show we incorporate
some of those ideas I mean I don't
really know
Al Franken for 2020 says Jennifer
Froderman I don't know about that I
don't know that I don't know that he can
win but what do I know I didn't think
Donald Trump was going to win so so I'm
clearly the last person who should be
asked about this mr. Tate says schedule
it so I I guess what is being alluded to
there is I could schedule a live stream
and then would people be notified that
I've scheduled it is that is that how it
works and then maybe it would get more
people watching or whatever I don't know
that that's something to look into yeah
the other idea I had is when we're
taping the show I could set up my phone
and livestream from like some side angle
in the studio so people could see what
the process is for when we record we
basically the record the show in four
segments for the one hour maybe that
would be interesting I don't know maybe
people would like would like that tell
people to enable notifications in the
upper right corner yes enable
notifications absolutely that that
sounds like something good people want
to know about our processes yeah so
maybe that's something that I would do
marine lepen was already asked to talk
about that book recommendations I've got
2 book recommendations for you one of
them I'm going to be doing on the show
tomorrow it's called the circle by Dave
Eggers and the concept is basically a
company like a Google or Facebook that
starts doing everything like mass data
collection and expanding into all sorts
of areas of life and sort of the way
that it can become not good
I just finished it it's from 2013 I
believe I'm gonna recommend it on the
show tomorrow number two I've just
started reading a book by Natasha I
don't want to get the last name wrong
the book is called addiction by design
it is by Natasha dau shul and it's about
basically machine gamble electronic
machine gambling which means video poker
and electronic slot machines but also
more broadly about just how casinos are
designed to keep people gambling to get
them gambling more and for longer
periods of time etc and it's fascinating
and I've been interested for a long time
about a lot of the site caught
behavioral psychology that goes into
casino design and it's really really
good I'm about a third to half of the
way through I will no doubt be
recommending the book on the show
eventually it's only ethical I feel to
recommend that after I've completed it
and also inviting Natasha for an
interview I think she actually teaches
maybe here at MIT or maybe at NYU I
don't remember someone asking whether
this is a gay Channel what does that
mean I mean is that is that really the
type of thing that that you're asking
about get Tony Schwartz on the show this
is the guy who wrote Donald Trump's book
the art of the deal I've tried to get
Tony Schwartz on the show and he has
never responded I would love to get him
on if everybody knows him
please tell him we're trying to get him
on the show
Netflix recommendations okay I mean I'm
up for doing this I'll pull let me pull
up my Netflix queue and I'll just tell
you some of the documentaries I have in
my queue right now I've got Killswitch
the battle to control the internet on my
list I've got the new chef's table
France on there what else do I have
forks over knives which is a documentary
about healthy eating I've got what else
do I have on here that people might be
interested in I started watching fittest
on earth which is a documentary about
CrossFit the CrossFit Games I got
through according to Netflix 47 minutes
of it I just don't know that I'm going
back to it I just it's I was repulsed by
it in the sense of I don't know I just I
just could not get through it what else
is on here Bob Ross I added Bob Ross
episodes to my Netflix queue it's very
zen to watch Bob Ross something about it
something about it is uh is very very
interesting all right I think I'm going
to end this live stream I don't know if
there's anything else to address it was
a test this is great I think one
possibility is live streaming when we
tape the show please if you're not
subscribed to the channel subscribe to
the channel we ran the numbers today oh
here's something interesting we ran the
numbers today if we can continue the
same rate of new subscribers through the
rest of the year that we've had so far
during 2017 we will hit the 500 thousand
subscriber mark sometime between
November 15th and December 1st which
would be huge in the time of an orange
president that would be absolutely huge
for us so that's exciting and that's
going on alright so anyway if there's
more ideas for stuff I should live
stream or whatever let me know if you're
not a member please sign up I know I
talked about this the the the show
exists because of membership we're
launching Amazon Prime in a couple of
weeks because of membership etc etc and
you know what if membership is too
expensive just ask me for a discount I
want people involved at whatever price
makes sense I there's nothing magical
about six bucks a month right I mean if
you want to get a 40% discount use the
coupon code
I voted seventeen take 40% off I really
don't mind we just want buy-in buy-in
from people is what matters
I'll do another live stream soon thank
you